hey tone people welcome to the Reuben
report I'm Dave Reuben I've got Beth
Troutman Jimmy Dore with me let's jump
into nukes because President Obama
yesterday said that his biggest worry
isn't Russia it's actually that a
nuclear bomb might go off in New York
City I moved from New York about a year
ago so I'm feeling pretty good about
this but not only that but just a couple
days ago in the Netherlands a group of
world leaders got together to play some
nuclear war games
to sort of figure out the planning and
preparation and fall out no pun intended
if a nuclear bomb was to go off in a
major metropolitan area so each world
leader had a computer tablet with
touchscreen options to make one of four
responses to a series of four scenario
films played out by actors so they
literally were watching actors act out
this this situation in the war game a
terrorist attack with an atomic dirty
bomb takes place in the financial heart
of an unnamed but Western metropolis
this is probably New York if it's in the
case of the United States and in a
competitive environment with a ticking
clock the world leaders had to make
rapid choices before the results were
presented to the group followed by
discussion so that I think this is
really fascinating so there basically
we're sort of playing like a real-time
half video game half acted out real
people response thing to something
pretty horrific so I'll start with just
the the base level thing is this
inevitable is a nuke going off in one of
our cities anywhere not just the United
States is it just ultimately inevitable
that this will happen well let's hope
not I mean I hope the idea is that
diplomacy communication things like that
can prevent a nuclear weapon a nuclear
bomb from going off in one of our cities
the thing that I found really
fascinating about this was Chancellor
Merkel mm-hmm thinking that this was
such a strange thing for these leaders
to be doing and I found that as a woman
hilarious because women we sit around
watching guys play video games thing
like this has no real-world application
this isn't going to help you achieve or
do anything and you've got Chancellor
Merkel in this situation with these men
playing on their tablets in this kind of
war game scenario thinking this isn't
what we really need to be focusing our
time energy and attention on is a war
game video game going to prevent this
from going off I would say no I don't
think that this is necessarily gonna be
the way that we're gonna prevent it from
happening but I I I think I would like
to think that it's not inevitable and
that's a very rose-colored glasses way
of looking at things but I don't want to
live in that kind of fear yeah well you
can't live in that kind of here I
actually that's a pretty great visual I
picture now angle of merkel as the
mother and all the rest of the guys
downstairs playing video games you get
outside and crazy kids
what do you is it inevitable that this
kind of thing I mean with the way dirty
bombs and that now it can be done in a
suitcase and all that is it inevitable
no matter how much they prepare that one
day this kind of thing is gonna happen
so I I when I first heard Barack say
that I thought I can't believe that it
hasn't happened already and then I
thought about it a little bit more and I
realized that well remember they tried
to have a couple of terrorists and an
SUV in Manhattan right and they couldn't
even get the freaking SUV bomb to blow
up right so this guy's basically got a
firecracker in his car and he can't get
it to work so and then there was the guy
with the bomb on the plane he couldn't
get it to work and so I'm like I think
even if they do get a dirty bomb they
probably won't get it to work they won't
get it we have lucked out a couple times
right with yeah with the shoe guy and
the underwear guy things that don't
really work out what do you make of
Obama saying this though the way bizarre
because he is so measured and controlled
so it's one thing if he truly isn't that
concerned about Russia I think that's
okay and we have to let diplomacy work
but the idea that he just suddenly out
of nowhere said well you know our most
important city it might be destroyed by
it seems sort of out of character for
him it seemed like a strange political
move I mean in my mind it was him trying
to take the focus off of Russia off of
Putin off of what's going on in all his
the criticism that he's getting for his
foreign relations his PO so you think he
was just like oh let me say the craziest
thing possible that are scare the [ __ ]
out of everybody that was one of the
things that that was my first instinct
reaction whenever I heard him say that
because suddenly if you hear the
president say that then your fear goes
in a different direction yeah I can't I
thought about like well one of the
people in New York thinking when they
hear that you know you imagine if you're
a kid in school and the President on TV
says we're worried about someone blowing
up
you're the bomb what the half are you
kidding me should I be scared all the
type of presidents saying and I'm too I
thought that was irresponsible of him to
say it like that would scare the [ __ ]
out of people living in there and I also
think it's funny that whenever they call
it a dirty bomb yeah it just it makes me
laugh a little because you know my
parents always castigating me for
swearing in my comedy so much why you
got to be so arrogant and that sounds
like the bomb is just coming all the way
it's going
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] such a
dirty Bob look obviously we're not privy
to all the stuff that's going on with
these games or what's really going on
with who has nukes and all that kind of
stuff and scientists that you know
defect from countries and all that but
do you think these games actually do
anything cuz they've been doing these
for years this isn't the first time
they've done this kind of thing but it
makes me think if a nuke was to go off
somewhere let's let's get out of America
for a second let's say it went off in
Paris how about that do you think the
games would actually matter he's going
freakin French of freedom prize you're
still on that freedom ride man do you
think the games would mean anything
because I feel like there would be such
chaos and such a cascading effect of
lunacy that none of the things that
they're doing would really would really
matter I couldn't agree with you more
yes so you try to plan for a nuclear war
huh hey let's fly a flag plan for when
your head blows up okay
what should I do after my head blows up
well first you put a bandage around it's
like no it's oh I think it's all you
know once a nuclear bomb goes off that's
it games over
right don't you think I do yes they
seemed I mean they have I guess they
have to be very diligent but they they
hijacked a plane and flew it into
buildings in New York and we invaded
Iraq and Afghanistan what do you think
if someone blows off a bull who else
have we're gonna strike somebody with a
nuclear bomb yeah I mean it's one goes
off it really seems like a domino to me
yeah well that is a good point because
if one went off here we would nuke
somebody we somebody we did a week we
would nuke somebody even even with Obama
who obviously isn't as militant let's
say although he's done some strange
things with drones which we'll get to
later as is so is this just really like
you know every science-fiction movie
I've ever seen where humans are just
going to destroy the earth and we're
gonna have to go live on Elysium or on
Mars or something is that really where
we're all going with this I think a lot
of people would say
yes I think a lot of people would say
that humans have been destroying the
earth since humans became humans this is
just a quicker way you should edgy stuff
today what do you think is this humans
are we gonna just do it to ourselves
between greenhouse gases and global
climate change and everything else I
mean yeah well I wouldn't buy property
in Florida yeah
I'm not I don't think we're gonna make
it past 2050 I don't think we have to
worry about Social Security running out
of money I think we're not gonna be dead
before I say Miami is gonna be
underwater and like people don't real
yes it's what I'm saying I wouldn't buy
property in Florida and you know the
whole thing people forget like Syria
what's happening in what's destabilizing
that whole region is a drought that all
started because of a drought and people
came into the cities protesting and then
the police overreact and it started this
whole thing so you know they talk about
climate change having political
political impact it's happening right
now
focusing on because that's a much larger
problem and something that's really
happening I mean we shouldn't be
necessarily thinking about playing a
game and wondering what would happen if
a nuclear bomb went off we actually have
something that's like a nuclear bomb
that's going off consistently that's
causing huge problems it just takes a
longer period of time you think we have
some progressives around here we started
with nuclear war we brought it around to
climate change there you go all right
let's talk politics I thought this was
pretty interesting Nate Silver who
everybody loves this guy right here
addicted the last election he's a big
numbers guy who now is part of ESPN he's
doing sports he got out of the political
world basically and he's doing sports
but he did have some interesting
thoughts on 2014 basically that the
Republicans are gonna win back the
Senate which is a scary scary thought oh
we've got a bunch of quotes actually we
think the Republicans are now slight
favourites to win at least six seats and
capture the chamber the Democrats
position has deteriorated somewhat since
last summer with President Obama's
approval ratings down to 42 or 43
percent which is down from about 45
percent and as compared with 2010 or
2012 the GOP has done a better job of
recruiting credible candidates with some
exceptions okay so silver does urge some
caution there these aren't you know
mind-blowing numbers that Republicans
are automatically going to win but it is
sort of interesting
and what I sort of glean into this is
that this is an Obamacare thing that the
Republicans have sort of won the
messaging somehow that we can't have
socialized medicine and not everyone has
a right to health care and all that do
you think that's what this is about that
they've somehow scared enough people to
think they have to be voting for them oh
definitely I think their people are yeah
oh my god my health care chains that
might that might get cancelled people
don't know what what's going on was that
people even know what's in their health
care plan until they get sick so
everybody's running scared everybody's
running free but Nate silver you know
it's no I think of Democrats way over
reacted to this right because he's not
saying that's going to happen he said
there's a slight chance that that might
happen that's how much stock people put
in what he's because of what happened
last time with Romney but don't forget
that he also nate silver was wrong in
2012 no 2010 I think when he predicted
that the Democrats would lose again the
Senate and they ended up gaining seats
yeah so he's that always correct yeah so
well that is a good point nobody's
always correct you know of course these
number guys that's a you know that's why
he's working for ESPN now it's a lot
easier dealing with sports numbers than
political numbers but what I was
thinking about this was that the
Republicans as far as I can tell have no
particular message other than
everything's against Obama so is is
anyone fired up for the Republicans
that's what I think is interesting here
people are saying we're gonna vote for
the Republicans in 2014 but is anyone
actually voting for them or they're just
voting against Obama I think in a lot
this happens a lot with midterm
elections people to do tend to vote
against what the current status quo is
and the Republicans do have a strong
message in you know attaching their
horse and carriage to the Affordable
Care Act they do have a lot of messaging
that they can use and they wasn't wrong
in predicting and he wasn't he was he
was actually I think maybe dead-on in
predicting that 2014 we might see
Republicans take over the Senate the
good thing that this does for the
Democrats though and you'll already see
this happening they can take this
message exactly and they can use it to
raise funds and fund these campaigns but
we do have about ten Senate races that
are really important for the Republicans
really important for the Democrats we
have Democrats who are stepping down
South Dakota isn't
you've got senator Johnson who was
retiring and you've got a really popular
former governor running in that state
Mike rounds could could take over that
seat that gives you a Republican North
Carolina is gonna be an interesting race
Kay Hagan won that Senate seat from
Elizabeth Dole back in 2008 when North
Carolina was a blue state for the first
time in my lifetime and it went back to
red in 2012 so Kay Hagan is gonna have a
tough race looks like Tom Tillis is
gonna be maybe one of the best possible
candidates you got two speaker the house
there in North Carolina there are some
people who are it's a risk for some of
the Democrats but that's what happens in
midterm elections we've seen it history
repeats itself we've seen it over and
over again and I think Nate was actually
making kind of a safe prediction and
suggesting that it might happen
interesting so do you think this is sort
of shows the strength of our democracy
in a weird way that in the midterms we
do often vote against the incumbent
president because it is a little bit of
check of powers which we seem to have
completely lost I would in normal times
I would say yes but I would say that the
Republican Party has gone so far off the
rails that now the Democrats are
Republicans and so we're not actually
getting a cut so as far as a government
that's representative of the people's
will we certainly don't have that right
now at all I don't think I mean look
where 90% of the people wanted gun
restrictions and gun legislation didn't
happen what does that mean that means
that our government we're like it's a
banana republic you know it's like who
would they're only serving their donors
they're not serving us which means that
what we really need is a different kind
of campaign financing I come back to
this all the time when it comes to
politics yes so campaign finance which
we we talk everything we do here The
Young Turks is about money in politics
and who's bought and sold why do we not
even have any discussion about campaign
finance anywhere we used to have that
mccain feingold thing what happened that
thing disappeared and now it literally
is not in the news anywhere because the
people who are supposed to be talking
about it is the media right the Fourth
Estate right and they're not talking
about it because the people who pay
their salary and sign their checks want
to have influence in politics they now
work for these major corporations for
instance right so Brian Williams and
David Gregory they work for General
Electric I'm
your defense contractor they of course
want to have influence on the government
so they're not gonna go on their news
show and say hey we gotta get what we're
doing it's horrible we have to get rid
of it and by the way the Iraq war is
[ __ ] and we process profited off of
it so they're not gonna do any of that
and that's the problem the people the
criminals bought the news media after
they bought the Congress so now there's
no watchdog anymore and that's why the
only people talking about it is us yeah
well okay so that's speaking of us or is
the online news thing now we're slightly
off we started here but is the online
news thing just to wrap this all up are
we the only estate that's left yet can
stop this thing I hope I hope so because
if you really look at the way the world
is working especially this younger
generation that's where we're getting
our news we're looking to the people
online to inform us and and talk to us
and if we as an online community end up
getting more attention then ultimately
don't they have to follow suit doesn't
mainstream media have to follow suit
it's it's terrifying to think about now
because of the overt when when the
Supreme Court overturned campaign
financing and we created all these super
PACs it wasn't it was basically like
money laundering for campaign finance
and it's difficult to discuss it now
because you have to dig in a different
way dig really deeply to find out who is
financing what and how and whom well
said and I can promise you guys that
we're not bought and sold and don't
trust the Democrats don't trust the
Republicans trust yourself okay all
right let's talk a little bit about
immigration we actually have not done
much about immigration on this show and
I saw a Rasmussen survey that was really
interesting about it what Americans
think about immigration right now so
let's look at some numbers 78 percent of
likely US voters believe everyone should
be required to prove his or her
citizenship before being allowed to
register to vote
29 percent believe laws that require
proof of citizenship before allowing
voter registration discriminates against
such voters and 61 percent say laws do
not discriminate up three points from
this time last year okay so as I said we
have not done a tremendous amount on
immigration so I'm glad that we're
talking about this and this is one of
these things that it's always an issue
and we sometimes talk about it a little
bit more and then suddenly we forget
about it and it's hard to figure out
which parties for what the 78 percent
let's just talk about that
that seems pretty legit to me that
basically 80% of the country saying you
should at least be able to prove your
citizenship to vote does that seem like
a sort of baseline way to start well I
think it seems like we've been
discussing it so much in the media in a
fear-based way but when you really look
at the numbers for things like voter
fraud they're so incredibly miniscule it
really isn't a huge problem but we've
kind of now made it this whole
immigration issue in a fear-based issue
more than an actual election issue but
the reality of the matter is it it does
requiring this kind of voter ID it does
and will continue to discriminate
against women against people who are in
lower income brackets against the
elderly and and the majority of this is
all political because the people who
that it affects do tend to vote all
right so if you look at this it's
happening in red states it's happening
in red states all right before I let you
jump in Jody what what's the rationale
because this is what people say all the
time about why why is it that having IDs
would discriminate against women well
one of the reasons is because it costs
money to end up getting those IDs
whether it's a birth certificate that
you have to use if you have to have a
copy of a birth certificate that cost
money you know fifteen dollars twenty
bucks it costs money to get a driver's
license it cost money to get a passport
and it also requires transportation to
certain offices in order to get some of
these documents and that can be
discriminatory against people who don't
have the funds to do that I understand
the idea of being registered to vote I
understand the idea of making sure that
voter fraud isn't a problem but really
if you look at it it hasn't been a huge
problem so okay so I'm so I get all that
for sure but I basically agree with the
the people that say you should at least
have to prove that you're legally in
this country to vote am i a crazy
conservative on this issue well I mean
you have to prove your ID that you're 21
to buy beer so I don't think saying that
just proving that you live in this
country is not a guaranteed right in the
Constitution right so that's really the
difference there but III think that
if you once you are I mean once I was
informed about the ramifications of a
voter ID law I was against the voter ID
law because they know they can
scientifically prove that it's going to
it's gonna eliminate a certain
percentage of people from voting for all
the reasons she just said right because
they're poor and they don't have access
right right people like well I got an ID
well some people don't there's a 90 year
old woman who's been voting her whole
life and she doesn't have transportation
and she doesn't have money and she lives
on a fixed income and she doesn't have
access to get to that stuff but she can
vote and it'll say but no you can't vote
now because we're not gonna you can't do
these certain things that we're gonna
change so there is again this is a
solution in search of a problem
there is no voter there is no voter
fraud nobody's going and voting twice
it's not happening so the only reason
you would want to implement this is to
do is to make sure you tilt the favor
and so in favor of the Republicans and
you discriminate against some of the
Democrat votes that's the only reason
you would do this and to that point it
does seem that the Republicans are the
ones that want this all to happen all
these voter ID things so they're not
doing it out of the goodness of the
country they're doing Arizona North
Carolina yes yes just like the guy from
Pennsylvania we've seen that clip a
bunch of times where the guy said a
voter ID which is gonna guarantee the
state of Pennsylvania from Mitt Romney
done you've seen that clip that's why
they do it then pretend again the news
media pretending that it's a legitimate
argument or not or exactly what they're
doing isn't voter suppression that why
isn't every reporter screaming from the
top of their lungs about voter
suppression in America that's because
they're bought and paid for and they
don't want to piss off half the people
who want to suppress the vote right so
what would you guys say to Bill O'Reilly
who's on TV every night saying that if
they if you let these immigrants that
are already in the country the people
that are here illegally but they are
acting as US states if you let them in
they all vote Democratic in it will be
the end of the Republican Party which
may in a weird way be bad for our
political system if we really only
became a one political thing even though
we're pretty much a one political thing
is but what would you say to that
argument I would say that is that's just
fear-mongering that's just trying to
scare people into believing that there's
a problem that really just isn't a
problem you know if they're there making
the discussion about something that
isn't a
a huge issue there were so many other
things that we should be focusing on and
talking about and this is a way to try
to maintain control in in these very red
states yeah and also ninety-five percent
of the people that are here even if
they're here illegally are perfectly
legal people within our borders you know
I mean they're working jobs and have
families I know people personally who've
had families split up and people been
deported that can't see their children
for 20 years I mean all kinds when bill
o'reilly says well we can't let all
these immigrants come here because
they're gonna vote Democrat and the
Republican Party well what that really
means is hey there's a bunch of people
are we're gonna have to appeal to with
our policies now that we don't want to
have to appeal to with our policies so
we can just not keep them away from
voting so we can just keep on appealing
to a narrower and narrower base of
people that's exactly what they're
saying oh my god we're gonna have to
address the reality that what we want
America isn't what most people want in
America holy [ __ ] yes
then you should have to change your
problem your party's a platform or you
go away right and the thing is in
America we're all children or
grandchildren or great-grandchildren a
bridge give us your tired your poor your
huddled masses somehow we don't want
anymore so final thought on this because
obviously we talk about immigration
forever but what do you think about
securing the border because that does
seem like a legitimate argument to me at
least that first somehow we should be
able to secure the border and then you
know to stop new immigrants from coming
in illegally while we deal with the
issue not that we ever do anything in a
correct order but at least like at that
argument at least make some sense to me
well yeah I mean one of the it's a it's
it's definitely an important issue to
think about we have all of the the
legislation really in place to deal with
illegal immigration we just don't have a
lot of real enforcement we are we are
backwards we all we do do things kind of
in the in the wrong way we do approach
things in a in a cart before the horse
kind of way when it comes to immigration
is one of them when it comes to things
like immigrate cuz for the last five
years we could have been dealing with
border issues just deal with figuring
out how do we secure the border and then
say okay we've dealt with that now we
can deal with the people who are here
and the people who want to get in but we
never deal with any
the correct order well no of course that
well it's it's because there's this
crazy you know dual infla or interests
right so corporations big farming
corporations big AG
we're business they want a cheap labor
but then they don't want them to be able
to vote so they they can vote into a
union right so they it's it's that push
they want them here to work but they
don't want to treat them like human
beings legislation like there are people
who are here and people are willingly
paying them under the table and paying
them tax free and those laws aren't
being enforced because there are so many
big corporations who are benefiting from
that kind of thing so that it's already
there we've established what's the
illegal but it we aren't necessarily
enforcing it because there's a benefit
that is the you right Jimmy about the
the irony of the Republicans because
especially the Mexicans that come in
they work at jobs that Americans don't
seem to wanna work and they bust their
asses for 18 hours a day doing the
hardest labor-intensive jobs and then
they don't get much for a return and
that's good for the corporations and
really we know the lazy Mexicans coming
in here taking our jobs taking our jobs
they want this gig but I'm keeping it
people okay all right I really love this
story so the government has basically
been actively trying to destroy three
great companies and yeah it comes down
to money
Tesla uber and airbnb so they're all
doing interesting innovative new
business models that are changing the
way people communicate and commerce so
let's look at some info about the three
of them and then I'll explain further so
if you don't know about Tesla they built
an electric car that people actually
want to buy there's a lot of them here
in LA they boldly sell directly to their
wealthy customers rather than subjecting
them to auto dealerships which helps
keep the cost down it gets rid of the
middleman and because auto dealers
account for as much as twenty percent of
the state sales tax legislators work
against them that was happening in New
Jersey as here we go New Jersey
Legislature added more burdens to rules
already banning direct sales of cars to
customers
now Tesla's effectively can't be sold in
New Jersey so this is an electric car
that we talk about all the time and what
are we doing we're regulating it into
oblivion let's look at the next one uber
we
we have here and I used last night it's
an app driven car service that connects
drivers and riders and minutes it
presents a threat to traditional taxis
and ride services obviously rather than
fight for customers by cutting fares or
increasing the number of cabs taxi
commissioners and City Council's are
instead trying to regulate uber out of
business on the grounds that it provides
unfair and unsafe competition yeah
because the taxi guys had a monopoly and
now they're not happy that because of
our apps we can figure out a way to do
this cheaper and more pleasantly
actually and then finally Airbnb which
is web site that allows people to rent
out apartments and homes therefore
despised by conventional hotels and
cities who rely on travelers and
tourists taxes Austin charges hosts an
annual licensing fee and limits the
number of participants Portland has
banned it in residential neighborhoods
rent controlled advocates in New York
City are teaming with up with the
hospitality industry to try to shut it
down okay so basically what you have
here are sort of three crowd sourced and
in a way crowd funded businesses that
are making better products that people
want and what's happening of course the
government is jumping in and trying to
tax them away the Airbnb one is the
easiest example I think because the the
hotel lobby is powerful and they don't
want people being able to rent their
rooms easily you you own your room I'm
pretty sure even if you're renting
you're allowed to rent your room out
usually what do we do in a situation
like this because these are do you guys
use these three any combination of these
three things yeah I've used uber used
Airbnb uber is actually really it's it's
a great app and an easy way to get from
point A to point B and one of the things
especially if you're a woman is you can
read these reviews of drivers and you
feel a little bit safer and another
great thing is that drivers can then
review passengers to not to pick up
so-and-so because he was a rowdy pasture
a passenger she was a rowdy passenger
this isn't I mean government has done
this throughout history and this is such
a complex issue of me thinking about
Tesla this isn't the first time that
we've tried to kill an electric car you
know this is happening again and and
this is all gonna tie into the things
that we've been talking about think
about media being owned by these major
corporations think about Tesla you had a
couple of Tesla's that caught on fire
for different reasons and it became this
huge news story that they're suddenly on
and the number of Tesla's that actually
caught on fire minuscule compared to
other cars and all of this kind of stuff
is interconnected all of this kind of
stuff is all about taxpayer dollars it's
all about lobbyists it's all about the
money that's going into fund these
campaigns it's all this stuff that we
have actually been talking about and it
is complicated it's not just about these
apps this stretch is pretty far yeah so
Jimmy I hate to beat our money and
politics thing again but this is this is
like a very personal example I think
it's different than the political
example of our politicians being bought
bought off for some foreign policy
interest or something like that this one
uber should be allowed to exist should
it not well I was always taught that the
definition of fascism is when that
government and corporations collude to
screw the workers right is that that's
pretty much right so so that's what's
happening here
so that's what this is right so we've
come up with something that helps the
consumer and the government steps in and
says nah that hurts the business so
we're not we're gonna protect the
business and not the concern of the
citizen which is the same thing that
happened when senior citizens were going
to Canada to get cheaper prescription
drugs because Canada does a very same
thing and negotiates the their
profession drugs prices with the
pharmaceutical companies which the
United States does not do so they would
go there to get them cheaper the
government then stepped in because the
pharmaceutical said hey we're losing
money from these people buying it
cheaper in Canada so the government did
do that and that is the definition of
fascism and by the way we should note
that it's not that they're colluding
just with business it's a certain type
of business because these are businesses
that pay taxes but they're not the ones
that are on the end with the politicians
right so it's actually it's more
nefarious even than just saying it's
fascism because it's not just about
business because these are businesses -
the government could be in business with
them but they're in business with their
old guys and that's even more perverse
in a way you know what I mean we've sort
of evolved and have these great three
great things an electric frickin car
that we've all been waiting for and the
government is still figuring out a way -
how do we quash this thing yeah well I
mean think about it it's happened it's
happened throughout history politics
doesn't stay in touch with exactly what
the people are are moving forward with
and this is another you
prime example of it and hopefully now
because we are interconnected and we're
using apps that we all will as as
citizens and I'm going to try to be
positive here because I don't want I
don't want to be you know depressed
throughout my entire life and I entire
day but hopefully we can and what we
should do is is speak out as voters and
speak out as consumers I mean Adam Smith
said it it's the free hand of the free
market if we all are moving in that
direction
don't cab drivers don't don't hotels
don't other people have to step up their
game shouldn't they have to step up
their game and I would love to think so
that I can sleep at night and wake up
and you know not want to cry and stay in
bed I would like to think that we do and
that we can try to have some level of
control over it as consumers because
these these businesses are going to
continue making money and government and
politics as as usual they have to catch
up and they are always 20 years behind
so to that point is is the saving grace
of this do we need frickin Facebook to
come in and buy uber because Facebook
could potentially fight the government a
little bit you know I mean they'd have
the money and the lawyers maybe like is
somehow these giant corporations are
they gonna be the one stuff to buy the
cool things to push out the middle guy
well I mean that certainly sounds like
one solution but that sounds like a
horrible solution yeah it's just like
well we need set we need to have we need
a benevolent corporation to fight
against a nefarious government that
doesn't seem right right and by the way
Facebook not so benevolent not that bad
right so they all seem to be they're all
hands are all dirty and yeah I mean
we're good we need another Teddy
Roosevelt you know we need a guy to come
in and bust up the trust and get the
government back to the people
perfect anything for that one I think
all right let's talk about drones you
know what everyone when you picture
drones and you see these things on the
news all the time it's always a drone
somewhere in the Middle East usually of
course and Yemen or something firing and
and usually killing innocent people and
double tapping and all that stuff that
we talk about all the time here but you
know we are getting drones here and
they're going to be delivering our
packages and they're also going to be
stealing your Wi-Fi and figuring out
it's on your phone yeah let's let's take
a look at some video of a new drone
that's coming out that's a hacker he's
using technology installed on a drone to
grab cellphone information from people
below this technology has been used on
cellphones and laptops one day it could
be installed in a larger aircraft think
helicopters or small planes I'm down the
road and I've seen lots of devices it
must be the people walking down the road
you can also see your usernames
passwords credit card information and
get this in some cases your home address
yeah so that's why we talk about drones
all the time because we're doing it over
there but to loosely quote George Bush
it's gonna end up coming over here I
mean look even if they're not going to
be shooting us which Rand Paul has
talked about you know you're gonna walk
out of 7-eleven they're gonna drone
strike you so even if it's not that
level this is pretty scary stuff because
we know that they're taking our
information already in the metadata and
all that but now that we're gonna have
drones flying around they're gonna have
access to all this well it's the same
thing that's been happening I mean
people have been creating these you have
fake Wi-Fi hotspots and stealing
people's information the difference now
is that it's mobile and these little
quad copters that are being used in
photography and used in videography
they're inexpensive and it's easy it's
now mobile and that makes it more
terrifying but this technology has
existed it's one of the prices sadly
that we have to pay for the convenience
of using our phones to bank using our
phones for email using laptops and
things like that we it's it's it it
becomes our responsibility to be aware
that these things do happen and we have
to be really careful with how we
approach Wi-Fi with our cell phone
devices if it's existed this has
happened before it's just now like I
said it moves around and it can it can
get more information more quickly but if
you think about it I mean I work in a
business that's all about online videos
I mean that's what I talk about all day
long and I find the people behind them
it's not hard actually to find all of
this information I can do it in 10
minutes just with Google searches and
looking through Facebook and looking
through the things that people post and
Twitter feeds and Instagram feed you
think about the nine minutes you'll be
able to save when you have your own
that's the thing Jimmy who do you fear
more do you fear just the hacker the guy
that's gonna do this or do you fear the
government doing this which do you think
is actually worse for us you know I mean
I of course I worry about both of them
but I guess I'm more worried about the
government that seems cuz because they
would be shielded from prosecution
things like that they could yeah yeah I
would be boroff I mean this is I don't
you know they say privacy I don't know I
mean what are we supposed to do they
it's I just assume that they know
everything about me at all time it
doesn't matter what browser I used to
surf the web whatever they're gonna get
it if they want it and it just seems
like somehow we've it's a lot were
through the looking-glass right it just
seems over now and your idea of privacy
is done this life of being connected we
we like the way the world has a lot of
people do they like that everybody's
connected but that's the other side of
it that's the the price we pay but
because we're living our lives on line
all of that is accessible and not just
by drones like that's the thing people
are really scared because they're named
drone has this you know it's instills
fear in people's hearts but it's already
happening it's been happening every time
no I was never a waiter or in a
restaurant but I always thought about
like when you use a credit card to pay
and they used to do the click thing and
they would have all your information
right there any person who's a waiter or
waitress had you're in for your credit
card information on them and yet we
never worried about that and they could
have stolen it and used at any time they
want it so is that a little bit of
something decent about this that maybe
our information has been out there all
along and saying no cuz I know a friend
who wouldn't he wouldn't buy a plane
ticket using the internet because he was
afraid to put his credit card and in the
Internet I'm like so when you call them
up it just goes into their computer you
tell me telling it says yeah yeah you
gonna say if so I yeah I mean I guess
you know we've I guess she just crossed
your fingers and just be glad that
nothing has happened so far as
technology increases we just have to be
more aware we just have to continue to
stay aware of how to protect ourselves
and then businesses also have to step up
to the plate and protect with their you
know and credit card companies do that
now they say that you're not responsible
for fraudulent charges the problem
though is that we as consumers end up
paying the price
for that because the bottom line is
affected by how much money they lose to
fraud all the time we have to be
informed consumers we have to be we have
to protect our own information but we
also have to be aware and keep ourselves
safe because they're more of our
information is accessible than we think
and we're the ones putting it out there
are you saying you don't read the fifty
page thing when you sign up for iTunes
you don't have them you don't have your
team of lawyers with you sitting there
going through well Beth I don't know if
you want to sign this because right
nobody and no one has the time to do
that because we connect everything
through our we live our lives online
yeah final point on this I think the
through the looking-glass I think is the
perfect way for this are we in a really
interesting time right now where for a
while we had all this stuff let's say
for the first ten years of mobile phones
and the internet we all had it
we all loved it everyone found poor and
everyone was excited now we're in the
through the looking-glass part which I
don't know how long it's gonna last I
feel like we're in like a three-year
thing here of everyone going [ __ ] we had
all this stuff we love it but we also
hate it and now what's the what's the
other side you know I mean am I giving
you something I'm giving you a little
esoteric there is yeah I think that it's
actually going to continue to to
increase there's a great book that came
out called the circle it's David Eggers
and it's this book that's written about
the concept of total transparency total
transparency the idea is that the
company that he created in this book
represents a company kind of like Google
and as people you you're always going to
have the people who say I don't want any
more technology I don't want any more to
happen but the way that the world moves
you end up almost being forced into it
in the book total transparency means all
people in government constantly having
cameras on them all people everywhere
constantly having cameras and
broadcasting that to everyone and the
weird thing about it is is that as you
read something like that you can see
that something like that could easily
happen because as we move forward with
all of this technology we get more
accustomed to it we get used to it it
doesn't feel as scary it doesn't feel as
intimidating and we keep moving forward
with it will will we stop will it stop
think we needed more technology in like
1992 you know and then suddenly here we
have this world oh we have a phone that
has more technology in it than the
Apollo that went to the moon so you know
we keep we we we don't stop it we keep
buying into it we keep moving with it
because we have this whole concept that
it's better to be connected it's better
to to put our lives out there we can
they become narcissistic in a way it's
that progress bring this home Jimmy well
you know what they say on the definition
of a narcissist is that someone who's
better-looking than you all right well
this leads us to a perfect segue for our
final segment here because there are a
bunch of apps that are popping up that
are purely to give us online anonymity
if that actually exists we've got a list
of a couple of them
there's conf ID which erases your text
messages right after they're read
there's whisper which shares secrets
anonymously and there is yet yak
anonymous social chatroom so this is
perfect considering the topic we were
just talking about so going to your
point of the circle which if you guys
are watching if you haven't seen the
clip right before this will annotate so
you can get right back over there about
everyone being completely transparent
with everything is that is the anonymity
thing the next thing before that you
know I mean first we have to first it's
we put all the stuff out there which
we're all doing now next it'll be we'll
all do it anonymously and there's plenty
of people doing that already and then
after that we get to the place of total
everything else it doesn't surprise me
that this is a trend right now but
didn't we start with the internet kind
of having this didn't we didn't isn't
that how people started in these chat
rooms that it was anonymous and people
were talking to each other under you
know some fake screen name and now
because of things like Facebook and
Instagram and you have a profile picture
it became a little more public it's
strange to me because we've become this
this culture of sharing and we have
become narcissistic in a way like we
want everyone to know our ideas and our
thoughts it's strange what I think a
selfie quick post-its whatever my new is
weird
exactly but it's it's strange to me that
people feel the need to share their
deepest darkest secrets with their
friends without their friends knowing
exactly who they are I mean what happens
to conversations you know the argument
is well if somebody is having an issue
with substance abuse or if someone is
having a real personal problem what
happened to actual personal contact
where you confide in somebody and say I
need your help and instead of putting it
out there for all of your friends to
judge and then sit and discuss I know
that it's anonymous but your friends you
know they're gonna get together and say
do you think that that was Bobby do you
think that I think that he would be the
person who said that this is like gossip
on a weird new level I don't think it
will I hope it doesn't last because it
seems like it's opening a door to more
negativity than positivity so but could
there be something cathartic about this
online anonymity thing I mean if you had
an app if you were just having a crazy
day and frustrated by something and you
didn't want to tweet it with your name
attached to it you know something really
angry that you could just click on one
of these things get it out there and
feel a little better and move on would
you like that the thing with the whole
online it's just that everybody being
online everybody's opinion matters just
as much as everybody else's opinion and
it requires increasing levels of cruelty
just to keep up go to any video on
YouTube check out the fourth commenters
comment it always rips the third
commenter because the fourth commenter
is always a jerk and the fifth guy the
newcomer tries to find common ground
among everyone and for that for that the
sixth commenter impugns his sexuality so
you know they also say that the problem
with anonymity online is that it could
creates bullies right you could bully
but let's remember who's the biggest
victims of bullying it's the bullies
right they're ostracized they're
stigmatized and they're created treated
like monsters in society and to all the
bullies out there I just want to say it
gets better
do we need anonymity now more than ever
because of all the NSA's look I don't
even believe that any of these apps
truly work because I'm pretty sure that
if the government wants to get in there
and figure out that they can somehow
track it to your IP address
your computer or something related to
your phone well let's pretend for a
second that these things truly are
anonymous
is there any at that point then it has
some worth right because we need to be
able to share secrets and with
everything going on at the NSA but why
do we need to share secrets online this
is what the were strange to me if you're
thinking about putting your information
out there online you need to assume that
at some point somebody's going to figure
out exactly who it is if you want to
maintain anonymity if you want to keep
your ideas anonymous why should I put
them out there online and just under
some shield you know so what about
somebody for example that's working for
the NSA now let's say that there's
things that Snowden hasn't revealed that
they know are even worse
something like this would be a
legitimate way of getting it out there
well and you but you think that with our
technologies that's my point I don't
believe that that it would work follow
the trail in the IP address you're right
and and figure out exactly who that was
like maybe I wouldn't be able to figure
it out just sitting on my computer
reading this anonymous quote but if
somebody wants to figure out who made
this post yeah I mean Google keeps
everything that you ever search for I
mean if you really want to I predict it
would be possible to get that kind of
information and again that's the risk
that we run in living this technology in
this world where everything is
accessible we it's the weird price that
we pay for the convenience that we
strangely want and for the my opinion
matters feeling that we all seem to
strangely one I'm not saying that we all
do but that as a society public people
talking about our feelings all the time
not us no no we're fine yeah I mean do
you think that there's some worth to in
a day and age of the NSA and spying and
all that do you think there if if they
couldn't track this stuff that there's
some worth to it I think there's I mean
you know many times I wished I was
anonymous online to be able to say
certain things so you know instead of
having to re sign into Google and under
a fake name and then go to that
commenter on YouTube and rip them a new
[ __ ]
can you just write your fake name here
so I can vaguely what you've been
writing about me my fake name is Jim
Dore no
funny every time I have you on the show
there's this guy Jim door who's like
that Jimmy door the judge he goes nuts
for it
fantastic and on that note I
want to thank my non-anonymous guest
Beth Troutman jimmy dore their twitters
are right down below subscribed liked
all that good stuff we're not tracking
you the government is but don't worry
about that and we will do it again
next week thanks good